all of the parameterizations we've done
so far have been parameterizing a curve
using one parameter we're going to start
doing in this video is parameterizing a
surface in three dimensions using two
parameters and we'll start with an
example of a torus
a taurus
or more commonly
known as a doughnut shape
a doughnut shape and we know what a
donut
looks like
let me draw it in a suitable i don't
have any suitable doughnut color so i'll
just use green so donut looks something
like this
so
it has a hole in the center
it has a hole in the center and maybe
the other side of the donut looks
something like that and we could shade
it in like that and maybe it's shaded in
like that that is what a donut looks
like so how do we construct that using
two parameters so we want to do is you
can just visualize that a donut if we
were to draw some axes here so that's
our doughnut let me draw some axes
so let's say i have the z-axis that goes
straight up and down so the way i've
drawn it here the doughnut's a little at
a tilt so the z-axis i'll tilt it a
little bit so our z-axis goes straight
through
the center of the donut
so that right there
this is going to be an exercise in
drawing more than ever anything else so
that is my z-axis and then you can
imagine the z-axis goes from there and
then
this on the coming out of here will be
my x-axis
that right there is my x-axis and then
maybe my y-axis
maybe my y-axis comes out like that
and the whole reason why i drew it this
way is that if you imagine the cross
section of this stone i'll draw a little
bit neater but the cross section of this
zone in the x z axis is going to look
something like this if i were to just
slice it in the x z axis it would look
something like that i'm slicing this is
the x z axis right
that
and that that would be the slice it
would trace out and we're thinking about
not a full doughnut just a surface of a
doughnut so we trace out a circle like
this if you were to cut the doughnut in
the positive z y-axis it's going to
trace out a circle that looks something
traces out a circle that looks something
like that right there and if you go out
here you're going to get circles it's a
bunch of circles so if you think about
it it's a bunch of circles rotated
around the z-axis if you think of it
that way we
it'll give us some good intuition for
the best way to parameterize this thing
so let's
do it that way
so let's start off with just the
z-y-axis i'll draw it a little bit
neater than i've done here
so that is the z-axis
and that is
and that is y
just like that and let's say that the
center of these circles
let's say it lies on you know it can lie
when it when you cross the z y axis it
cr the center sits on the y axis i
didn't draw it that neatly here but i
think you can visualize
so it sits right there on the y axis and
let's say that it is a distance b
away from the b from the center of of
the taurus or from the z axis so it's
the distance of b it's always going to
be a distance of b
right it's always if you imagine the top
of the doughnut let me draw the top of
the doughnut
if you're looking down on a donut
so let me draw a donut right here
so if you're looking down on a donut it
just looks something like that the
z-axis is just going to be popping
straight out the x-axis would come down
like this
and then the y-axis would go to the
right like that
so you can imagine i'm just flying above
this i'm sitting on the z-axis looking
down at the donut it'll look just like
this and if you imagine the cross
section if you this circle right here
will look
just like that this circle right here
that part of the top part of the circle
if you're looking down
would look just like that and this
distance
this distance b is the distance from the
z-axis to the center of each of these
circles so this
distance let me draw in the same color
from the center to the center of these
circles that is going to be b and it's
just going to keep going to the center
of the circle's b
that's going to be b
that's going to be b that's going to be
b all of from the center of our torus to
the center of our circle that defines
the stores it's a distance of b so this
distance right here
that distance right there is b
and from b we can imagine we have a
radius
a radius of length a so these circles
have radius of length a so this distance
right here is a this distance right here
is a this distance right there is a that
distance right there is a if i were to
look at these circles these circles have
radius a
and what we're going to do is have two
parameters one is
the angle that this radius makes with
the x z plane so you can imagine the x
axis coming out let me do that in the
same color
you can imagine
the x axis coming out here so this is
the x z plane so one parameter is going
to be the angle with our rate between
our
radius and the x z plane we're going to
call that
angle or that parameter
we're going to call that s and so as s
goes between 0 and 2 pi
as s goes between 0 and 2 pi when it's 0
it's just going to be you're going to be
at this point right here and then as it
goes to 2 pi you're going to trace out
trace out a circle that looks just like
that
now we only have one parameter what we
want to do is then spin this circle
around what i just drew is just that
circle right there what we want to do is
spin the entire circle around
so let's define another parameter
let's define another parameter we'll
call this one t and i'll take the top
view again this one's getting a little
bit messy let me draw another top view
as you can see this is all about
visualization so let's say this is my
x-axis
that is
my y-axis and we said we started here on
the what on the z-y plane
we are b away
from the z axis so that distance is b in
this diagram the z axis is just popping
out at us it's popping out of the page
we're looking straight down it's just
like the same view is right there and
what i just drew when s is equal to
0 radians we're going to be out here
we're going to be exactly one radius
further along the y-axis then we're
going to rotate as we rotate around
we're going to rotate and then come all
the way over here that's when we're
right over there and then come back down
so if you look on the top of the circle
it's going to look like that
now to make the doughnut we're going to
have to rotate this whole
setup around the z axis remember the
z-axis is popping out it's straight
looking straight up at us it's it's
coming out of your video screen
now to rotate it
we're going to rotate this circle
around the z axis
and to do that we'll define a parameter
that tells us how much we have rotated
it
so when we're over so this is when we've
rotated 0 radians at some point we're
going to be over here
we're going to be over here and we would
have rotated it this is b as well and
our circle is going to be
looking like this this is maybe this
point on the circle on our doughnut
right there at that point we would have
rotated it let's say t radians so this
parameter
of how much have we rotated around the z
axis how much have we gone around that
way we're going to call that t and t is
also going to
vary between 0
and
2 pi and i want to make this very clear
let's let's actually let's actually
draw kind of the domain that we're
mapping from to our surface so that we
understand this i guess fully so let me
draw some and then we'll talk about how
we can actually parameterize that into a
to a position vector vector-valued
function
so
right here
let's call that the
t-axis
that's remember how how much we're
rotated around the z-axis right there
and let's call this
let's call this down here
our s axis and i think this will help
things out a good bit
so when s is equal to 0 and we vary just
t so they're both going to vary between
0 and 2 pi so this is right here is 0
this right here is 2 pi let me do some
things in between this is
pi
this would be pi over 2 obviously pi
over 2
this would be 3 pi over 4. you do the
same thing on the t axis it's going to
go up to 2 pi
let's do that so we're going to go up to
2 pi
2 pi i really want you to visualize this
because then the parameterization i
think will be straight fairly
straightforward so that's 2 pi
this is pi
this is pi over 2
and then this is 3 pi
over 4.
so let's think about what it looks like
if you just hold s constant at 0 and we
just vary t between 0 and 2 pi and let
me do that in magenta right here
so we're holding s constant and we're
just varying the parameter
2 pi so this if you think about it
should just form a curve in three
dimensions not a surface because we're
only varying one parameter right here so
let's think about what this is remember
s is
let me draw it let me draw my axes
so that is my x-axis
that is my
y-axis
and then this is my getting messier and
messier
that is my z-axis
right actually let me draw it a little
bit bigger than that i think it will
help
all of our visualizations all right so
this is my
x-axis
that is my
y axis and then my z axis goes up like
that z axis now remember when s is equal
to 0 that means we haven't rotated we
haven't rotated around
this circle at all that means we're out
here we're going to be b away and then a
away again right we haven't rotated
around this at all we're setting s is
equal to 0.
so essentially we're going to be b away
so this is going to be a distance of b
away and then we're going to be another
a away the radius the b is the center of
the circle and then we're going to be
another a away we're going to be right
over there so this is a plus b away and
then we're going to vary t remember t
was how much we've gone around the z
z-axis this was these were top views
over here so this line right here in our
st domain we can say when we map it or
when you parameterize it it'll
correspond to the curve that's
essentially the outer edge of our donut
if this is the top view of the donut it
will be the outer edge of our donut just
like that so let me draw the outer edge
and to do that a little bit better let
me draw the axes in both the positive
and the negative domain it might make my
graph a little bit easier to visualize
things
positive and negative domain this is
negative z right there
so this line in our ts plane i guess we
could say this magenta line we hold s at
0 radians and we increase t this is t is
this is t is equal to 2 pi
that's t is equal to pi
this is t is equal to 3 pi over 2
all the way back to t is equal to 2 pi
this line corresponds to that line as we
rotate as we ro as we increase t and
hold s at constant at 0.
now let's do another point
let's say when s is
s is at pi
right remember when s is at pi we've
gone exactly pi is 180 degrees when s is
at pi we've gone exactly 180 degrees
around the circle around each of these
circles so we're right over there and
now let's hold it constant at pi then
rotate it around to form our donuts
we're going to form the inside of our
doughnut so when s is at pi and we're
going to take t from zero so when s is
pi and t is zero we're going to be this
was the center of our circle we're going
to be a below that we're going to be
right over there
and then as we vary as we increase t so
as we move up
as we move up along
holding s at pi
and we increase t
we're going to trace out the inside of
our doughnut
we're going to trace out
the inside of our donut that will look
something
like that that was my best shot at
drawing it and then we could do that
multiple times when s is pi over 2 i
want to do multiple different colors
when s is pi over 2 we've rotated
up here we've rotated exactly 90 degrees
right pi over 2 is nine degrees we're at
this point and then if we vary t we're
essentially tracing out the top of the
doughnut
right so let me make sure i draw so the
cross section the top of the donut we're
going to start off
right over here
so when s is pi over 2 and you vary it
right
and then you vary t
i'm having trouble drawing straight
lines
and then you vary t
it's going to look like this that's the
top of that circle right there the top
of this circle is going to be right
there top of this circle is going to be
right over there top of this circle is
going to be right over there so then i
just connect the dots it's going to look
something
something like that that is the top of
our donut if i was doing this top view
would be the top of the donut just like
that and if i want to do the bottom of
the doughnut just to make the picture
clear
if i make the bottom of the doughnut the
bottom of the doughnut would be let's
see if i kick s is 3 pie over 4 and i
vary t that's the bottoms of our
doughnuts so let me draw the circle so
it's right there
the circle is right there you wouldn't
even be able to see the whole thing if
this wasn't transparent
so take you'd be tracing out the bottom
of the donut just like that i know this
graph is becoming a little confusing but
hopefully you get the idea when s is 2
pi again you're going to be back to the
outside of the doughnut again that's
also going to be in purple
so that's what happens when we hold the
s constant at certain values and vary
the t
now let's do the opposite what happens
if we hold t at 0 and we vary the s
so if we hold t at zero and we vary the
s
so t is zero that means we haven't
rotated at all yet so we're in the z y
plane so t is zero and s will start at
zero
s will start at zero and it'll go to 2
pi it'll go to 2 pi this is this point
sorry pi over 2 that's that point over
there then it'll go to pi
this point is the same thing as that
point then it'll go to 3 pi over 4. and
go to 3 pi 4 and then it'll come back
all the way to 2 pi so this line
corresponds to this circle
right there
we could keep doing these
if we if if we pick when
s is
pi over 2 oh sorry when t is pi let me
do a different color that's not
different enough
when t is pi over 2
just like that
we would have rotated around the z axis
90 degrees so now we're over here and
now when we vary s s will start off over
here and it'll go all the way around
like that so this line corresponds to
that circle
i could keep doing it like this
when t is equal to pi that means we've
gone all the way around the circle like
that and now when we vary s from 0 to pi
over 2 we're going to start
all the way over here and then we're
going to vary all the way we're going to
go down and hit all those contours that
we talked about before and i'll do one
more just to kind of make this the
scaffold
clear this dark purple hopefully you can
see it when t is 3 pi over 4 we've
rotated all the way so we're in the x
we're on the x z plane we're on the x z
plane and then when you vary s s will
start off
over here and as you increase
s
you're going to go around
the circle
around the circle
just like that and of course when you
get all the way back full circle t over
pi over 2 that's the same thing you're
back over here again so this is going to
be we can even
shade it the same color and hopefully
you're getting a sense now the
parameterization i haven't done any math
yet i haven't actually showed you how to
mathematically represent it as a vector
value function but hopefully you're
getting a sense of what it means to
parameterize
by two parameters and just to get an
idea of what these areas on our on our
st
on our st plane correspond to onto this
surface
onto this surface in our in in i guess
you could say an r3 this little square
right here let's see what it's bounded
by it's this little square i want to
make sure i pick a square that i can
draw neatly so this square right here
that is between on when you look at
t it's between this t is equal to zero
and pi over two so between zero is
t between zero and pi over two
and s is between zero and pi over two so
this right here is
this
this part of our taurus
this part of the torus if you're looking
at it from an outer edge from or sorry
from the top it would look
like that right there you can imagine
we've transformed this square i haven't
even shown you how to do it
mathematically yet but we've transformed
this square to this part of the doughnut
now i think we've done about as much as
i can do on the visualization side i'll
stop this video here in the next video
we're going to talk about how do we
actually parameterize using these two
parameters remember s takes us around
each of these circles and then t takes
us around the z axis and if you take all
of the combinations of s and t you're
going to have every point along the
surface of this torus or this doughnut
how do you actually go from an s and a t
that goes from zero to two pi in both
cases and turn it into a position
vectored a three dimensional position
vector valued function that would define
this surface we're going to do that in
the next video